[موسيقى]
لم تنم ليلتها على كيف تقاطرت المسيره
الروسيه لكن الهجوم السادس من نوعه خلال
شهر يقول الاوكرانيون انهم ابطلوه
يتحدث الروس في المقابل عن احباط هجوم
اوكراني ليس بنك اهدافه على اليابسه انه
بحسب موسكو هجوم بزورقين مسيرين على احدى
سفن اسطولها في البحر الاسود تصدت له
سفينه دوليه
ما يدور هنا على الجبهه البحريه لا يبدو
خارج سياق الجدل بشان حركه الملاحه
البحريه وان كانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلنت استئنافها في خليج
بالبحر الاسود وليست هذه التطورات كما
يبدو ببعيده عن ملف تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه
تؤكد موسكو استحاله العوده للاتفاق الذي
يتيح ذلك دون مشاركتها في حين تتوافق كييف
ولندن على اهميه وصول امدادات الحبوب الى
الاسواق العالميه
ويقول رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك
ان بلاده تعمل من قرب مع تركيا لاعاده
العمل باتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر
الاسود
الاوكرانيون يزيدون على ذلك تعهدنا بتوفير
حمايه للموانئ وممر الحبوب
اجتماعنا اليوم مع القاده ناقشنا بالتفصيل
سبل حمايه مؤسساتنا وموانئنا وممر الحبوب
في البحر الاسود في مواجهه ارهاب الصواريخ
والمسيرات الروسيه نحن الان بصدد اعداد رد
قوي على هذا الارهاب الروسي
في دائره الارهاب ايضا تضع اوكرانيا
الهجوم الروسي بمسيرات على البنى التحتيه
لميناء الدانوب ومستودعات الحبوب جنوب
غربي اوديسا المساله لا تقلق الاوكرانيين
وحدهم ما تفعله روسيا في اوديسا مدمر
مازلنا قلقين من احتمال ان يوسع جيش
الروسي رقعه اهدافه على منشات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه لتشمل هجمات على سفن مدنيه في
البحر الاسود وقد حذرنا من ان روسيا قد
تهاجم اهدافا مدنيه ثم تلقي اللوم على
الاوكرانيين بهدف اخفاء مسؤوليتها ونحن
نواصل مراقبه الوضع من كتب
الوضع الميداني ما زال لاهبا على مختلف
الجبهات والمحاور هنا يجدد وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني عزم قوات بلاده مواصله قصف شبه
جزيره القرم وجسرها لتدمير ما يدعوه
الخطوط اللوجستيه للعدو ذاك جنوبا اما على
الجبهه الشرقيه فتستميت القوات الاوكرانيه
في محاولاتها احداث ثوره في الخطوط
العسكريه الروسيه
الروس لا يظهرون ايه تاثر بهجوم اوكرانيا
المضاد ذاك الذي قال الكرملين انه فشل مع
ذلك فالحرب ما زالت قائمه
هذا مجلس الدومه وقد تبنى للتويه قانونا
يرفع سقف سن الاستدعاء للخدمه العسكريه في
روسيا من سبعه وعشرين عاما الى ثلاثين